I THINK WE HAVE A QUORUM SO WILL
GET UNDERWAY HERE THE. JANUARY
TENTH TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
MEETING OF THE ASSEMBLY
INSURANCE COMMITTEE.
IS NOW OPEN.
WANT TO WELCOME OUR NEWEST
MEMBER MISTER TIM GRAYSON.
TO THE. TO THE COMMITTEE WELCOME
TIM.
YEAH.
AND.
LET'S TAKE CARE OF PARK LET'S
ESTABLISH UC WARM.
DALY HERE. MACE.
BIGELOW.
CUBBY ARROW.
CALLED A RUN.
CHEN.
CHIU.
COOLEY HERE.
COOPER.
FRAZIER FEAR. GIPSON.
GRAYSON HERE.
HARPER.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK U. TRACY AND.
LET'S GET RIGHT INTO OUR.
WE HAVE ONE ITEM ON THE AGENDA.
AB TWO OH SIX WAS POLLED.
AND WE'RE ON AB FOR SEVENTY NINE
BY MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER
WELCOME.
I THINK YOU.
I'LL BE BRIEF.
S. I HAVE RUN THIS BILL MOST YOU
HAVE VOTED FOR IT YOM THREE
TIMES NOW. THAT IT'S BEEN VETO
THANK YOU IT IS VERY THOUGH I
NARROWED ITS ESPECIALLY.
.
FOR THOSE WHO HAVEN'T REALLY
SEEN AS MUCH I'VE COMPLETELY
NARROWED IT IT IT HAS TO GENDER
BIAS IN WORKERS COMPENSATION TO
ONLY DEALING WITH THE ISSUE OF
HOW. BREAST CANCER IS RATED
RIGHT NOW UNFORTUNATELY.
DOCTORS TO WIN A A WOMAN
THEY'RE USUALLY.
FIRE IN FACT ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY
FIREFIGHTERS AND AND PEACE
OFFICERS HAVE BREAST CANCER
THAT'S BECAUSE ON THE JOB. THEY
GIVE IT A RATING AYE IF YOU'RE
NOT OF CHILD BEARING AGE OF ZERO
PERCENT IF YOU'RE OF CHILD
BEARING AGE UP TO FIVE PERCENT
THAT'S WHEN YOU LOSE A BREAST.
AND IN SOME OF THE WAY AT SUCH
UNFORTUNATELY.
THE DOCTORS HAVE TO LONG RELIED
ON IN MAY GUIDE WHICH BASICALLY
SAID.
DESCRIBES A FUNCTION OF A BREAST
IN A WAY THAT LIKE PROBABLY WE
WOULD AND I AGREE WITH.
IT'S ONLY FUNCTIONALITY BEAN TO
BREASTFEED OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE
THAT'S A WHOLE FIVE PERCENT SO I
HAD THIS THIS PUTS IT IN LINE
THIS WILL MAKE DOCTORS LOOK AT
MORE HOLISTICALLY PUT IT MORE IN
LINE WITH THE WAY WE WRITE. ON
THE LAST OF THE PROSTATE LOTS
OF.
OTHER THINGS THAT HAPPEN.
TO MEN WHEN THEY HAVE CANCER
AND SO I I I I AM HOPEFUL THAT
THIS LIMITED IT TO JUST THIS I'M
FROM THINGS THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE IS THAT IN PAST WE WERE
HOPEFUL CAN ACTUALLY GET SINUS
TIME.
SO WE HAVE A COUPLE OF.
.
FOLKS WHO WILL SPEAK ON IT.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS YOU TODAY. I'M CRYSTAL
SCHOENFELDER IMMEDIATE PAST
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
APPLICANTS ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
AS WELL AS A FOUNDER AND CHAIR
OF THE ASSOCIATIONS WOMEN'S
CAUCUS.
ZERO NOTHING AS THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SAD THAT'S WHAT
THE BOOK THE AMA GUIDE SAYS WE
GIVE TO OLDER WOMEN WHO BRAVELY
SURVIVED A BREAST CANCER INJURY
DUE TO THEIR WORK.
BUT HAVE TO LIVE WITH THE
AFTERMATH OF THAT CONDITION. AND
WHAT ABOUT YOUNGER WOMEN THE
BOOK SAYS TO GIVE THEM BETWEEN
ZERO FIVE PERCENT PER THE
DOCTOR'S DISCRETION.
WHAT DOES THE BUT GIVE OTHER
pFIVE PERCENT EVEN A HUNDRED
PERCENT?
THE LEGISLATURE HAS THE DUTY AND
THE POWER TO REMEDY THIS GENDER
INEQUITY.
HOW'S THAT AB FOR SEVENTY NINE
IS A SIMPLE STRAIGHT FORWARD
COST EFFECTIVE SOLUTION. IT
MANDATES THAT STATE APPOINTED
DOCTORS CONSIDER ALL
CONSEQUENCES OF BREAST CANCER
INCLUDING THE SURGICAL PROCEDURE
LOSS OF FUNCTION OF THE UPPER
EXTREMITY YOUR EXTREMITIES SKIN
DISFIGUREMENT PAIN AND TREATMENT
THE FACTS.
AND EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY NINE
GETS RID OF THE DISTINCTION
BETWEEN OLDER AND YOUNGER FEMALE
BREAST CANCER SURVIVORS.
BECAUSE TELLING AN OLDER BREAST
CANCER SURVIVOR THAT HER
CONDITION IS WORTH NOTHING IS AN
ABSOLUTE INSULT ADDED TO THE
INJURY.
THE BEST WAY TO REMEDY THIS
GENDER BIAS IS THE STATE'S
WORKERS IN THE STATE'S WORKERS'
COMPENSATION SYSTEM IS AB FOR
SEVENTY NINE AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YEARS.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHRISTINE BAUM ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS WERE
PLEASED TO BE IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. OF
FIREFIGHTERS ON THE FRONT LINES
OF THE. DEED.
THE RISK THAT THEY FACE EVERYDAY
DO NOT DISCRIMINATE THEIR GENDER
AND WE WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL THAT
ASSURES THAT THEY ARE
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST. WHEN
THEY DO SUFFER A JOB CAUSED
INJURY.
SO WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
OKAY OKAY.
WELCOME KANSEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS BOMA.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
.
COMMENTS.
MISS CUT BUREAU HAS A QUESTION.
YOU KNOW WHAT DUMB MISTER BUREAU
IF YOU I THINK THERE'S SOMEONE
WHO WANTS TO SPEAK.
.
ON THE OTHER SIDE.
WANTS TO SPEAK FROM THE. FROM
THE GRAY AREA.
OKAY GO AHEAD SIR.
YEAH GO AHEAD.
SHARE MEMBERS JASON SHELTER HERE
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
ON WORKERS COMPENSATION WANT TO.
FIRST ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT THE
AUTHOR SAID THAT WHICH IS THAT
THIS IS A VERY DIFFERENT BILL
AND WE SAW LAST YEAR IN THAT WE
OPPOSE LAST YEAR.
TO BE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
MOVE AWAY FROM IT A PORTION AND
BASS POSTURED OF DIDN'T LOOK AT
THE ISSUE. AND WE'RE HAPPY NOT
TO HAVE A POSITION TODAY.
IT'S THEIR NEW AMENDMENTS WERE
LOOKING AT THEM I THINK THE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT SOME
REASONABLE I THINGS THAT WE NEED
TO DISCUSS SO I THINK OUR
APPROACH YEARS GONNA BE SIT DOWN
TALK TO THE AUTHOR TALK TO THE
SPONSOR. TALK THE ADMINISTRATION
AND SEE WHERE WE CAN GET SO WITH
THAT THANK YOU WE HAVE NO
POSITION DONOR DIVERT EITHER WAY
TODAY. OKAY.
THANK YOU.
STATE PLAYING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF GREAT
POWERS AUTHORITIES WE DEADLINE
OUR COMMENTS LIKE THOSE MADE BY
CCW SEE AND APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR AND HER STAFF FOR MEETING
WITH US LAST WEEK. AS WE
CONTINUE TO ANALYZE THE BILL AND
ITS RELATED POLICY IMPLICATIONS.
A GOOD MORNING SANDRA BORRERO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
Q..
ANY OTHER FOLKS ARE AND I DIDN'T
I WASN'T AS CLEAR AS I SHOULD
HAVE BEEN ABOUT SPEAKING. IN
SUPPORT. OR IN OPPOSITION.
STATE CATALDO REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF INDUSTRIAL
MEDICINE AND SURGERY. THE
CALIFORNIA NEUROLOGY SOCIETY IN
THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY FOR
PHYSICAL MEDICINE REHABILITATION
SUPPORT THE BILL.
ANYONE ELSE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OR NEUTRALITY.
AND.
MISS FLETCHER IF YOU COULD
ADDRESS I GUESS THERE'S A A
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS.
I AM HAPPY TO TAKE THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENT THAT THAT'S.
AND APPROPRIATIONS THAT'S WHERE
I'LL TAKE IT.
YES. WHO SOUNDS LIKE SORT OF?
SOUNDS LIKE WHEN I I I CAN TALK
TO THAT CHAIR IN A.
IF YES WOULD BE HAPPY TO THAT'S
A GOOD POINT SOUNDS LIKE A
WINNER.
ANYTHING ELSE YOU'D LIKE TO SAY
OR DO YOU WANT A CLOSER QUESTION
I THINK SORRY.
NO THERE IS A REALLY QUESTION I
JUST WANTED TO.
.
TO.
APPLIED THE AUTHOR FOR FREER.
TAKING THIS BILL THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO ME THE BOTTOM LINE
IS.
AGREE TO HAVE A ZERO PERCENT
RATING.
FOR IN ANY INJURY THAT REQUIRES
YOU TO IT
EXTRACT TISSUE AND LEAVES YOU
INJURED BECAUSE THEM THE MUSCLES
ARE NOT THE SAME. THE WAY THAT
YOU'RE PIERCE YOUR STRUCTURE IS
SET UP IS NOT THE SAME.
IT IT THIS IS REALLY I THINK
REALLY REALLY VERY IMPORTANCE I
WANT TO ADD ON IS A CO AUTHOR IF
YOU WILL ACCEPT THAT.
AND JUST SAY THAT ARE A PART OF
THAT TYPE PART OF THE CHALLENGE
IS TO BE ABLE TO LOOK AT AT THIS
AREA AND TO SAY WHAT WHAT IS THE
VALUE. OF OF THE INJURY. HOW
DOES IT RELATE DIFFERENTLY MEN
TO WOMEN AND REALLY THE CREATED
EQUAL FAIL BECAUSE RIVER BEFORE
REALLY GOING TO GET WOMEN AND
NONTRADITIONAL?
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO TREAT THEM
WITH THE SAME RESPECT IN THE
SAME KIND OF.
SUPPORT.
AS THEY DO THEIR JOB AND AND
I'VE GOT TO THINK THAT I'M I
KNOW A NUMBER OF WOMEN THAT HAVE
HAD MASTECTOMIES ON THEY DON'T
HAVE THE STRENGTH. AND THE
ABILITIES THAT THEY HAD BEFORE
AND THAT'S IT WORKERS COMP IS
BOAST COMPENSATE FOR IS TO GIVE
YOU. BUT YOU BACK AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE AND THEN GIVE YOU THE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
TO DO YOUR WORK. ON WITH.
WITH THAT NEW CAPACITY SO THANK
YOU FOR DOING THIS I JUST WANTED
TO.
.
TO ECHO WHAT'S BEEN SAID
THINKING. THANKS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I JUST.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
AND HOPE THAT I CAN.
QUIT HAVING HEARINGS AND TALKING
ABOUT THE VALUE OF BRASS JUST.
WOULD BE GOOD TO ALLOW THAT TO
BE PROFESSIONAL HONEST.
I'M RECOMMENDING OF.
SUPPORT VOTE HERE.
WE APPROVED A SIMILAR BILL LAST
YEAR WE VOTED ON THE FLOOR THE
PREVIOUS YEAR.
THAT MOST OF US WHO WERE HERE.
SUPPORTED THAT BILL SO I SALUTE
YOUR CONTINUING EFFORTS AND
LET'S HOPE THIS TIME A.
THE IN. IS RESOLVED.
THERE'S MOTION SECOND ALREADY
SIR SO LET'S VOTE.
DALY BERMAN AYE DALY AYE MAYES.
MAYES AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE. COME HERE. COME
HERE I CALLED RUN.
CHEN.
I AM CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHU AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER. COOPER AYE
FRAZIER. FRAZIER AYE GIPSON AYE
AYE. GIPSON AYE GRAYSON AYE
GRAYSON AYE HARPER.
THAT ALLOWS ELEVEN ZERO VOTES
ELEVEN ZERO WAY TO GO. THANK
YOU.
ANYTHING ELSE FOR THE GOOD OF
THE ORDER IF NOT WE'RE ADJOURNED
THANK YOU. SO